Democrats all of a sudden getting tough
on crime but only to sabotage a
republican radical Manhattan D.A Alvin
Bragg wants to lock up Donald Trump as
he goes soft on violent criminals
the guys the poster child for not
Prosecuting crimes you can literally rob
a store a thousand times and be back
home in time for dinner Greg came up
with this idiotic idea that he had to
walk back you could stick a gun in
someone's face ask them to empty the
cash register but as long as nobody got
hurt only a misdemeanor in fact since
taking office thesaurus funded
heavyweight has downgraded 52 percent of
felony cases to misdemeanors but a
Year's old hush money payment to a porn
star that we all forgot about and that
the feds dismissed wow that demands the
full force of the law and an upgraded
felony charge all of this should come as
no shock the fix was in from the start
here's Brad campaigning on getting Trump
watch
a lot of people are wondering uh whoever
has this job
are they going to convict Donald Trump
look that that that is uh the number one
issue I'm the candidate in the race who
has the experience with with Donald
Trump I was the chief Deputy in the
Attorney General's office we sued the
Trump Administration over a hundred
times and you believe it should happen
uh yeah I I believe we have to hold them
accountable House Republicans seeing
right through Bragg's political shred
and want to haul them before Congress
he brags
about lowering felonies to misdemeanors
and not Prosecuting federal district New
York say this wasn't something they were
going to pursue the the previous
district attorney say this is something
they weren't going to pursue and even
this district attorney say he wasn't
going to pursue it and then what
happened president Trump announces he's
running for reelection and Shazam no now
we're going to pursue it
judge is he Bragg reaching the level of
prosecutorial misconduct he did it
during the campaign what are you talking
about he and Leticia James are focused
on Donald Trump you know the criminal
justice system is there to prosecute
people who commit crimes not to go after
each and every one of us to the point
where after seven years they think
they've got something they create the
crime to fit the individual that is an
outrage it is unethical it is
unprofessional it is the same thing that
Mark palmran said he was the United
States Attorney assistant USA USA with
the southern district in New York this
guy was known for going after
Republicans he then wants to work for
free for Bragg so that he can just get
Trump he writes a book on professional
unethical he could be brought up before
the character committee or the
commission uh on attorney conduct the
grievance committee but it doesn't
matter to them they don't care when
you've got a D.A like this who was
focused on making felonies misdemeanors
you go into a jewelry store with a
bazooka three people have a heart attack
drop dead but you don't shoot anybody
hey what is a misdemeanor your first one
hey how about a take off and take the
Bazooka with you no problem okay but he
is stretching to make a misdemeanor a
felony where he has no jurisdiction a
misdemeanor a falsifying a record he
gets it to be by the way statute of
limitations already passed in New York
is two years he then wants to raise it
to a felony by saying the crime he
intended to commit was a federal FEC
crime in a presidential race when the
FEC said there was no crime we're not
Prosecuting him and that's gone past the
statute of limitations and now this guy
says I'm going to make myself a hero and
make sure that we've got the first
president in American history indicted
and I'm bringing them in in cups are you
kidding me why not a virtual arraignment
if you have to do it at all you
politically corrupt leftist ideologue
that's what he is and the shame of this
is is someone who spent 32 years as a
prosecutor this guy is training people
not to prosecute criminals but to let
them out of jail and ignore the victims
of crime and he is responsible for blood
on the hands uh for the blood that's
been spilled by so many New Yorkers by
repeatedly letting out criminals over
and over again Jessica tarloff your
response to that
I said yesterday I did not think that
this was the avenue to go down I think
that the case in Georgia seems to be a
lot more serious it seems to be
something that a lot of people
um moderates Independents the Republican
side can understand how what Donald
Trump did in Georgia pressuring
officials to go out and find him 11 800
votes or whatever it was across three
different phone calls
um you know Rudy Giuliani and Lindsey
Graham they've all gone before the grand
jury before that that seems a lot more
serious and something people can wrap
their hands around there is a lot of
misinformation flying around about this
you know people talking about yesterday
John Edwards saying John Edwards said
the same thing he did get indicted he
was then acquitted as the judge pointed
out yesterday but there may have been a
crime here but one that you wouldn't
necessarily prosecute and obviously
Alvin Bragg has to deal with the fact
that he's on record saying that he's not
going to do anything about this once he
won the election and he had two top
prosecutors quit over it and now what is
the difference and I read an op-ed today
that I thought was really smart about it
to say I happen to think the the author
that there was a crime committed here
and it is an FEC violation but you need
to tell me why now why did you suddenly
wake up and decide this well the talking
point though about Alvin Bragg should be
paying attention to these things and not
these things coming from people who
represent districts that are more
violent than New York City really does
annoy me though so Kevin McCarthy
Bakersfield is more violent than New
York City Mike Pence talking about it
there are three cities I understand
she's not in office anymore in Indiana
though that are more violent than New
York City Indianapolis number 10 New
York City number 59. go home fix what's
going on there I don't particularly like
Alvin Bragg but it it rings a little
Hollow when you're going after them on
this front Okay John Edwards paid the
money to settle that case with donor
funds that's right Trump used personal
funds right but it was the
see violation if it was a campaign
contribution because it was even after
the Access Hollywood tape that that was
a violation of the rules 130 000 is
beyond not a campaign contribution since
he didn't pay from that that's what
they're doing right it was his own money
private settlement civil Dana well I I
would ask this to Alvin Bragg you know
how much is a mug shot worth to you and
is it worth losing all of your
credibility
um to be dragged through not just by
conservatives you have liberals who are
saying this is not the case to bring but
does this mean that much to you and is
that why the timing to the question of
the person who thinks it was a crime but
is that why is that you want this so the
Democrats seem willing to actually break
Norms because of the threat that
President Trump might one day break
norms and part of this also goes to just
democracy itself what do you know
there's liberal groups and conservative
groups that go all over the world to try
to counsel countries that are developing
democracies about how you treat
opposition this is not how you treat an
opposition it's a terrible example
especially because all this convoluted
was a misdemeanor it wasn't it was civil
it wasn't and if you if it is not clear
as day this is that the president
did not shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue
that's something that people could wrap
their heads around even in Georgia they
make a phone call but maybe maybe maybe
you could get there but if they do this
then anything else that comes after that
is not going to be taken seriously
because that already will be baked into
the cake in terms of the voters Minds
last thing for me is Politico did this
profile of Alvin brag and within it he's
described as Alvin Bragg is described as
politically averse
this guy
he he was definitely assertos funded
prosecutor he came in he turned upside
down the city's law enforcement as the
judge went through very clearly and to
say that he is not political it's just
insane he absolutely is and that's fine
and that's why just be upfront about it
if you are actually going to go go this
route and you are political and you
think you have a case and you're going
to bring it fine but be where the
consequences and I imagine that at the
end of 2024 they might not think the mug
shot was worth it what do you think
mental note don't go after Dana all
right okay I'm sorry about that I should
get here earlier uh first off he's
downgraded burglaries armed robbery's
possession of uh non-firearms uh and
drug cases but he's going to go after
Trump I thought it was very interesting
last week came out here the New York
Post had an exclusive story that Donald
Trump is evidently in a great mood he
says that he wants this front and center
he's loving being in the center of the
storm he wants the high profile arrest
he wants everyone to see how ridiculous
this is he wants it filmed he'll bring
his own camera crew but I agree with you
Dana you know bolsonaro left the country
because he knows he's going to be
arrested we sure have had to leave the
country because he knew he was going to
be arrested why he lost an election and
then like what he do when he's in power
it's an embarrassment to the country
that's what I care about most number two
uh what I think your stats might be
right Jessica this is what bothers me
most not that crime is high what are you
doing to stop it and there's a sense
among the uh police force here they're
not backed and he had D.A that does is
not clamped down so if there are these
cities in Indiana I'm sure you're right
are there police Chiefs looking to crack
down are they supported by local
officials are they looking to crack down
if they were cracking down in New York
City and we had the zero tolerance D.A
that said I'm going to the smallest
crime and the biggest crime I go well uh
Mr President you lived in the wrong City
for the wrong time this is a no-nonsense
D.A you're just part you're caught up in
the drag net but instead it's just the
opposite except him and I thought van
Jones said it back off this is not where
you want to go and Lindsey Graham likes
you better but he did tell me this
morning that he did testify in Georgia
and there's not a lot of there there
when you put these phone calls in
context it is basically a guy going man
how did I lose by a thousand votes
there's got to be a thousand votes as
opposed to find me a thousand votes
anywhere you can and then when you look
at Mar-A-Lago compare it to Joe Biden's
Pen Center and Joe Biden's house and uh
Joe Biden's lawyers house in Boston
that's kind of neutralized and I think
it's guy uh Trump up by 20 points game
on well that certainly settles it
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I
didn't Terry any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now